if we ever got to the chance to make a
venom movie together that would be super
cool but his movie would have to take
place in the MCU because I'm not giving
up my ticket I'm sorry I couldn't give
it to you sir
hey everybody is Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to digest some of
the spider-man marbles Sony News we have
a whole bunch of updates the plot
thickens and the conspiracy theories are
only going deeper everybody right now is
feeling Ronan Hawke I don't do that
don't give me hope but we'll break it
all down we're doing the Avengers
endgame and spider-man far from home
blu-ray giveaways all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best theory about what's gonna happen
with spider-man 3 as plot if it's just
Sony making that movie so yes there is a
chance that Marvel can still save the
deal there was a lot of back-and-forth
Sony finally issued an official press
statement on the whole thing apparently
all the news that we heard about
yesterday the deal falling apart was
someone on the inside the calls coming
from inside the building
so put all your tinfoil conspiracy hats
on it sounds like somebody inside the
deal is trying to influence it one way
or another using the fandom like you
litigate things in the press by leaking
details about big lawsuits or big
business deals it's a very very common
tactic that businesses use in Hollywood
but for those of you that are asking why
doesn't Disney make this problem go away
by just buying Sony Pictures buy the
studio the reasons why Disney can't do
that should be pretty obvious they
become a legit monopoly if you weren't
already worried about them becoming a
monopoly
additionally adding all the Sony stuff
on top of the Fox stuff would definitely
make them a monopoly the government
would probably never approve the deal
and Disney just spent almost a hundred
billion dollars buying Fox's assets so
there's no way that they would turn
right around in the next couple of years
and do the exact same thing with another
studio but the good news is is that the
rights to spider-man would revert back
to Marvel if Sony did sell their studio
to someone else or they stopped making
spider-man films but they're never going
to
stop making a spider-man films they make
way too much money on those so we got a
whole bunch more details about what's
going on with the future of spider-man
is just break this down top six style
because it gets a little complicated but
not quite as complicated as you think
six why did the deal blow up so it all
began yesterday afternoon when deadline
ran their story saying the deal fell
apart because Disney wanted 50/50
co-financing deal where Disney would pay
half of the money to make all the
spider-man films including the venom
movies in any other animated spider-man
films all the spin-offs that Sony is
making not just the Tom Hollands
spider-man films right now Sony pays for
a hundred percent of the production
that's why they make most of the money
on all the box-office
now there's a new report claiming that
those numbers are fake in what Disney
was actually asking for was a 30% stake
in future spider-man movies they're not
asking for 30 percent of the profits
they're asking for the right to pay for
30% of the production but then by
becoming a 30% partner they would wind
up making a lot more money in the long
term that was the deal that caused Sony
to walk away from the table like they
didn't even try to counter there were
other financial terms that Sony offered
which Disney turned down they were
pushing for the 30% that's when Sony
said flat-out no and then both parties
walked away from the table so 5 what
happened next is the outlets were
reporting that there was still a chance
that things could work out long-term in
spider-man might not necessarily be out
of the MCU for good after everyone set
the internet on fire yesterday there was
a Sony rep speaking to reporters that
claimed that the dispute between Marvel
and Sony was mostly just due to a
producing credit and then right after
that Sony issued their official press
statement on what had just happened so
I'm just gonna read their statement it
goes like this
much of today's news about spider-man
has mischaracterized two recent
discussions about Kevin Feige Zinn volve
mminton the franchise we are
disappointed but respect Disney's
decision to not have him continue as
lead producer of our next live-action
spider-man film I'll explain what that
means in a second we hope that this
might change in the future saying the
Sony might come back to the table but
understand that the many new
responsibilities that Disney has given
him including all their newly added
Marvel properties talking about all the
Fox Marvel stuff x-men Deadpool
Fantastic Four do not allow time for him
Kevin Feige to work on IP they do not
own the Disney does not own Kevin is
terrific and we are grateful for his
help and guidance and appreciate the
path that he has helped put us on which
we will continue
so for unpacking all that they say a
whole lot of stuff and they imply a lot
of behind the scenes things that were
going on this whole time they revealed
recently that Kevin Feige secretly was
helping them make all their other
spider-man movies of any kind without
any credit without his name being
anywhere on the movies going back to
Andrew Garfield era amazing spider-man
films even before that he had a lower
producer credit on the Tobey Maguire
spider-man films before Marvel Studios
really became Marvel Studios he was
working under a V Arad when they were
originally making those early spider-man
films so that means the Kevin Feige also
helped make the venom movie they just
didn't put his name anywhere on the film
so this is Sony doing major damage
control because their stock slid just a
little bit so of course their CEO the
president came out and said something
like look look look people are taking
this the wrong way that's not exactly
what's going on here but in that
statement when they editorialize about
Kevin Feige being way too busy to work
on their films which is kind of
laughable they're also saying that if
there were spider-man films that you
didn't like or you thought were bad the
Kevin Feige also helped on those two so
he's partially to blame if there are
things that you don't like about
previous spider-man films there are a
lot of people also wondering what the
Disney people did to make this deal fall
apart apparently it was also alan horne
Kevin feige's boss not Kevin Feige
himself who was negotiating for new
terms on this spider-man sharing deal 3
what does this all mean so you know put
your tinfoil conspiracy hats on it
sounds like during negotiations alan
horne kevin buguese boss said that kevin
feige
was way too busy to produce the film's
for almost no money like they've been
doing in the past because all the new
Deadpool x-men Fantastic Four films were
coming down the pipe but like Sony says
Kevin Feige has been shadow producing a
lot of their spider-man films this whole
time while he's also been making the MCU
a billion dollar enterprise so it's a
situation where Disney is telling the
in these negotiations the Kevin Feige
Gea's time is worth billions of dollars
like you can literally put a price tag
on it because of how much money they
made this year alone but Feige has been
working for five cents on the dollar
this whole time so they're wanting Sony
to pay for the pleasure a little bit
more like they're basically getting
their best asset who is Kevin Feige for
almost free so that's what Sony means
when they're saying we regret Disney's
decision to not have Kevin Feige
continue as lead producer of our films
so it's really Kevin Feige G's boss
who's saying we're not gonna let him
produce any more future spider-man films
into I saw a lot of you asking questions
about this further complicating things
is all the other non movie spider-man
projects going on the TV shows in the
video games you're a big fan of Marvel's
spider-man game one of the best games of
all time not just spider-man games but
one of the best video games of all time
Sony just bought insomniac games the
makers of Marvel's spider-man franchise
right now they're working on a sequel to
that based on that post-credit scene is
probably gonna revolve around the Harry
Osborn version of venom in Norman Osborn
Marvel actually owns the rights to the
spider-man video games so even though
Sony bought the game studio that made
that game they still don't own the
rights to the spider-man video games
they'll make a lot of money on whatever
the sequel is but most of all go back to
Marvel and Disney you may have heard
about all the live-action spider-verse
TV shows that Sony is developing with
Lord and Miller remember Marvel owns the
TV rights to spider-man meaning the Sony
has to get a contract with Marvel to do
all that stuff on the side so just
because the movie deal seems like it's
melting down around us doesn't mean this
Sony and Marvel have problems working
together on everything spider-man
related is the press release says it's
really more about the creative control
and the right to produce what the story
who the actors are how they make the
movies for the spider-man solo films
it's not so much about having spider-man
in the MCU so your number one question
what is the future of the spider-man
character in the movies right now well
as of right now per Sony's statement
they're planning on two more
Tom Hollands spider-man movies they
definitely plan on crossing him over
with venom we've all talked about that
Kevin Feige has confirmed it they talked
about live-action spider-verse but the
other thing that might have
and now is the you might actually see
spider-man in a rated-r film because
reports about the deal say that the
reason why the venom movie was
originally supposed to be rated R but
then at the last minute they turned it
into a pg-13 cut was because they wanted
to cross spider-man over with venom and
they wanted venom to be able to cross
over into the MCU but they were worried
that if they made venom rated R it would
cause a lot of problems for that because
the MCU movies will always be pg-13
Deadpool is kind of the exception to
that now with Fox but a lot of this was
all done before the Fox Marvel deal went
down
I think spider-man solo films are always
going to be pg-13 because he's so
popular with younger audiences they want
them to be able to go see the movie
what'll probably happen though is as
they try to put him in a rated R movie
that will be your venom versus carnage
film or maximum carnage like doing a
legit rated R version of carnage and
then spider-man is in it teaming up with
venom to stop him whatever you thought
of the venom movie I definitely think we
would prefer a rated R version of
carnage right now Sony has plans to
release spider-man 3 summer 2021 so that
still be during Marvel phase 4 so Disney
and Sony have two years to come back to
the table to work out a new sharing
arrangement there's still a chance they
could save this and spider-man won't be
out of the MCU completely but for now at
least for the next six months or so it
seems like Kevin Feige won't have any
kind of creative input as to what
happens with spider-man 3
everybody posters spider-man theories in
the comments below the Disney d23 Marvel
phase 4 panel is happening this weekend
I'll do videos for all that stuff in the
spider-man Marvel Sony situation is
still developing so if we get big
updates on that or if we hear about big
changes I'll do a new video about that
too while you wait for everything click
here for my spider-man video from
yesterday and click here to learn about
why the Russo's are talking about Nova
in Avengers endgame thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]